of course I'm concerned about the
potential impact it's one of the reasons
that I've taken devolution so seriously
because I think we need to get ready for
that moment but also think we need to be
very positive about it here in South
Yorkshire we're building what we're
calling a global innovation corridor so
a whole series of key anchor points
based around advanced manufacturing and
engineering so we're really confident
about our future we're beat about the
progress that we're making absolutely
determined to draw in more inward
investment from around the world
we've already successfully done that
with Boeing McLaren and with others so
we're confident about our future I think
I do have a bit of a concern that we
should never be seen to be talking down
our economy brexit is a massive moment
for our country there will be challenges
that it will be pretty but there are
also opportunities and here in the
Schieffelin City region what absolutely
determined to make the most of those
opportunities just think you say that
sometimes it's a bit too much doom and
gloom from the media potentially but
also from politicians I mean I'm the
mayor for an area of every constituent
part voted to leave the European Union
I'm the MP for Barnsley where nearly 70%
of people decided that they want to
leave the European Union now there were
lots of reasons for that but the view
that I take is that we need to make the
best of it so what were those reasons
and why do you think they do so strongly
I think many of the reasons were not
related to the European Union directly
but I think it was a view that parts of
the country like ours have been left
behind the truth is that we are still
grappling with the legacy of the 1980s
where we have that seismic shock to our
economy with the closure of the
steelworks and the pits and it is places
like this the factory 2050 here that
give us an opportunity to redefine
ourselves to grow our economy and create
very highly skilled well-paid jobs
because they say that if there is a no
deal then that will be catastrophic so
their company would a No Deal scenario
be catastrophic fortune we don't want a
No Deal for Yorkshire we want a deal I
think it would bring very significant
challenges and it is my job as
the mayor to make sure that we are
insulated against those challenges but
also that it doesn't become a
self-fulfilling prophecy
now I want us to be outward looking I
want us to be confident about our offer
which is a strong one this is obviously
a massively important job for national
government to get a deal that allows us
to continue to trade as close to the way
in which we've been previously able to
trade but from my point of view the
message that I'm sending out to the
world is that we're building a global
innovation corridor that provides an
amazing opportunity for people to come
and invest in our area and we're really
proud of that offer and we're going to
take you out in the world do you think
it's been shortchanged the north by
politicians Kathleen Westminster
undoubtedly I think that there has been
for too long a view in Westminster and
why to all the government could get away
with treating the north not in the same
way as people in the south would be
treated and I think I think look look at
the amount of national investment that
goes into transport infrastructure you
know we are dwarfed in the north here by
the amount of money that's spent in
London and the South East London is the
capital it's incredibly important that
they get the investment they need but
the levels of money that come into the
north of England simply are not
acceptable and I think we've reached a
point where there is an acceptance of
that I think people generally
acknowledge that we've been shortchanged
in recent times but the challenge for us
now is what we're going to do about it
and I'm absolutely committed to working
with leaders across the north of England
and the other mayors to make sure that
our voice is properly heard and acted
upon in government and in Parliament
there are problems of devolution there
aren't there is a pretty thorny area
because you know if you live somewhere
like Doncaster or Barnsley for example
then would you not be worried that this
is just going to be a case of taking
power from one city London and giving it
to another city
someone like Sheffield well Manchester I
think that is one of the challenges that
I will have to convince people why it's
in their interest to have a mayor and
the value that that will add to people's
everyday lives but I think going back to
the debate around brexit we heard time
and time again the mantra of take back
control and there were big questions
about political accountability
I believe the closer that you can place
political decision-making
to the people who will be affected the
best possible chance that we will have
of addressing the feelings of a
alienation that people undoubtedly have
now devolution is a really important way
at which we can do that I feel maybe
it's slightly lost its way a couple of
years ago we had George Osborne in
government who was a great champion for
devolution of the north
he's clearly no longer a part of the
current set up and I think that the
current government have just got a bit
to do to demonstrate to us in the North
that they continue to take it seriously
and the northern powerhouse as an entity
is the kind of the vehicle that we can
help to regenerate the north of England
and can reduce those structural
inequalities that existed for far too
long so as mayor of the Sheffield City
region we don't yet have an agreement
about the powers and the money that I
can draw down from it is a problem there
are lots of ways in which I can
hopefully add real value as the mayor so
we just put forward a really big bold
bid to government four hundred and
twenty million pounds to upgrade our
transport infrastructure but yes we
don't have final agreement about the
budget and the powers and people in the
in the regions just can't agree we don't
have an agreement at the moment and I am
working around the clock to bring the
local authorities together to reach that
agreement because if we want devolution
to work in the ship reseda region and
more generally across what the wider
Yorkshire area we need that agreement
and I think absolutely there is an
understanding that we've been
shortchanged in the north of England and
I think there is general agreement
devolution provides a way in which we
can reduce those structural inequalities
but we've just got to do the terms and
conditions around it and reach a final
agreement so we can get on with it and I
can draw down the money and powers I
need to do the job that I've been
elected to do
I wondered I'm wondering how you feel
the the system of the regional mayors is
working as well because you could argue
that from the outside it looks like a
bit of a boys club you've got a lot of
men doing the jobs you also got a lot of
people who used to work in Westminster
so if the whole idea is to take power
away from Westminster it'd be better to
get people with wood a range of
experiences and it can really challenge
groupthink of politicians not really
people like yourself to be both I think
I'm in a slightly different position in
that unusually I've decided to stay in
Parliament and that's because I think
the devolution is so important for the
northern end of our country we need
people who will champion it in
Parliament as well so that was the
reason that I took that decision a lot I
think there is a more general sadness
about the fact that we don't have enough
women wanting to serve in politics you
know my experience of working with women
in politics is they're extraordinarily
good at it
so I think there's a big questions for
us as politicians as a society as to why
more women don't want to step forward I
think it's partly about the political
culture that we operate in it's not a
particularly nice place to be
I saw a souring of our kind of political
atmosphere as we work through the debate
around the EU referendum and for many
incredibly talented highly skilled
experienced women they will look at that
and think why would I want to be a part
of it and I think that is really
depressing yes you know a bit but kind
of rufty-tufty character I think people
think long and hard about sort of taking
me on but they think you know frankly
less law and hard about having a go at
some of my women colleagues and I think
that is a source of great sadness for
our country and I see the abuse that
many of my women colleagues get it is
disgraceful it's not acceptable we all
need to stand against it and we need to
build an environment and atmosphere
politically that means that women are
much more kind of likely to put
themselves forward and want to do what
are undoubtedly very important jobs in
in politics I'm interested just to
finish off with a little bit people go
into these mayor jobs either to use it
as a platform to launch you know future
leadership bids or to just escape
Westminster and get away from you know
what's happening in Westminster today
like it very much so what count do you
call them well there is another way of
looking at it Sophia and I don't know
this will be hard for some people to to
understand but actually I'm doing it
just because I believe in it because I
think it's important because I think we
need someone who will commit heart and
soul to actually driving our region
forward Oz is a region with huge
potential but we need
somebody who can bring it or I can see
you're looking slightly cynically at me
but it is the case we need someone who
can actually get the show up and running
who can make things work locally and
regionally pull people together but also
be a voice for us on the national stage
in the end I took a view about who was
best placed to do that and sometimes
you've got to kind of put your money
where your mouth is and on that basis I
step forward people often see partitions
as and detached from the real world have
this kind of bubble like kind of guild
of existence but actually to be fair
you've had a very different life
experience too many people Westminster
you've served in Iraq and Afghanistan
you lost your first wife to cancer do
you think those experiences give you a
different perspective yeah I think they
do I think we're all products of our
environment I've had what you might
describe is a there's a pretty tough
paper round I think I see I'm very lucky
to have had those experiences because I
think it makes it much more effective or
what I'm trying to do now which is
difficult but in a different way but
ultimately what I think the public one
is people who they can place their faith
and trust in and I hope that they will
look at me as someone who will be
straight with them and will do the best
job that they can I don't get into kind
of sort of bluff for or kind of waffle
but I just see that there's a real
moment for our part of the country
to actually move ourselves forward and
you know that's why I'm here because I
really believe in global innovation
corridor there's something that we can
develop to drive our economy you know we
live with the legacy today of decisions
that were taken by a Conservative
government 30 or 40 years ago and I'm
determined to drive our region forward
and I see an opportunity to do that and
I think that is very exciting and it's
something that I'm absolutely committed
towards